When the war started February 28th, I
couldn't sleep for 2 weeks because I was
so anxious and afraid. I'm just worried
about the world. Yeah. So, March was
really hard. There were also some
attacks against me. There was clearly a
Samaritan campaign that was coordinated
because certain influencers were using
the same talking points.
>> On the last appearance you had on my
stream, you mentioned how you thought
the Patrick BD David show was going to
be a setup. You got it spot on.
>> Um, I will be on his show tomorrow. I I
I've agreed to go on a show. And you
look at guy like Peter Hexav whenever he
does a press conference, I swear to God,
it's almost like he talks war as though
he's having an orgasm. I mean, do you
get an impression where like he just
loves this, right? When he says like
negotiating with bombs, it's like he's
climaxing. I'm being amplified in uh
throughout social media. I don't think
it's organic. I'm being amplified and
given more prominence than I than I I
should be. The question is why is this
happening? One suspicion I have is that
this social division is also part of the
playbook. If this war is meant to move
towards uh the end of the world and the
great uh reset, then you need civil war
throughout the western world. Why aren't
we protesting this war in Iran? Why
aren't we protesting the what Israel is
doing in Lebanon? Why aren't we
protesting the fact that Israel seems to
be targeting everyone? Why why hasn't
anyone posted the fact that America at
the first day of the war killed the
leader of Iran which is against
international law and also killed 168
innocent school girls. Why are there any
protests against that? So all this is
really weird. And now you have AI and
the AI revolution. It's not about
replacing blue collar workers. You can't
do that. It's about replacing white
collar workers. the lawyers, the
accountants, the doctors, the
professors, the high school teachers.
The elite wants this war in Iran and
Trump Trump is doing that. As long as
Trump keeps this war going, then the
elite will let allow him to get get away
with anything. But once um you know,
he's out of office, then then he'll
he'll be destroyed. If you were to take
this theology literally, what what it's
telling you is that there's only 600,000
humans in this world and everyone else
is just an animal soul. Everyone else is
an animal that's taking up space. So
like you should try to clear up as as
many of them as possible. There are
these religious extremists in Israel who
do not see anyone outside Israel who is
not Jewish as a human being. That's why
that phrase like mowing the lawn, right?
>> You know like imagine killing people as
like mowing the lawn because you know
there are weeds and we have to mow the
lawn. Hello everyone. This is my third
interview with Professor Jen amidst the
war that he predicted on his YouTube
channel called Predictive History, as
well as a massive coordinated attack on
his character and his name because of
minor things like jokes about the
Messiah. Also, his internet moniker,
Professor Jang, although he's a high
school teacher, which he spells out in
his lectures, which many people seem to
have not watched and have only developed
an opinion based off of short clips. I
was very exhausted in this interview. I
have been editing my new main channel
video interviewing strangers about the
Iran war. I apologize for making a silly
mistake that I would have not made if I
had been able to sleep without editing
non-stop for the past several days. I
said angel Gibriel instead of the jin of
Eliss when it came to the origins of
Satan. Similar to Professor Jen who
mentions in this interview that he had
not slept for two weeks during the month
of March and his massive rise to fame
and also being glued to the news and
reading every single major development
going on in this catastrophic war. I
hope you enjoy this interview and please
forgive me. Also support the new video
on my main channel called Sneo on
YouTube. My second channel with the
stream clips like this one is my second
channel at Schneo. I hope you enjoy this
conversation.
Go go go go go go.
>> Hey, professor. Can you hear me?
>> Hi, Michael.
>> Good to hear from you again. How long?
It's uh it's been a while.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Well, it seems like a while
because uh the world is ending, but
yeah.
>> Yeah. Thanks. I don't even know if I can
call you a professor anymore. I'm still
going to call you professor.
>> Well, well, thank you. Yeah. No. Um I
don't know why in the middle of a war um
when there's so many real issues, the
issue that seems to upsets a lot of
people is whether whether or not I'm a
credential professor. And I've already
said I'm not a credential professor. I
teach at a high school. I don't have a
BA. Um it is something the internet
calls me. Uh in China people call me
professor as well because um it's a sign
of respect. So
yeah,
>> it's ridiculous. I mean again the guy
Medyusan, it seems like he's on the
right side about so many issues. I think
a lot of people don't actually watch
your long form content. So many people
that are part of this attack campaign
against you, they're seeing clips taken
out of context. One where you're making
a joke about the Messiah and it's like
does he want to start a cult? I'm like
he's so clearly joking. I watch your
lectures. I, you know, I really
appreciate the work you do and I didn't
get to see the new Trump one, but I
recently saw the the greater, no, the
Patria Horizon. I'm always taking notes.
And you say in almost all your lectures
that you're a high school teacher, so
they really don't have anything on you.
>> Yeah. I I don't understand why they're
obsessed with this particular issue. Um,
so there there have been three major
attacks against me. The first is um
whether or not I'm a professor and
clearly I'm not a professor and I've
been very honest and candid about this.
The second is that um I am an
anti-semite. Um that I'm a Holocaust
denier and um that's something that I've
addressed before. And the third is that
I'm a spy. And depending on the time of
day, I'm either a spy for Mossad or a
spy for the CIA or for the Communist
Party uh or I'm a secret society. I'm
scoring bones. I you know, it's it's
silly how how many acquisition
accusations I I get uh that I'm a spy.
Um but we we can talk about any of this
if you want.
>> I mean, there's uh you said it
correctly. There's so much more
important things to talk about right
now. There's been major developments.
I'm sure you saw the tweet from Trump
saying, "Praise be to Allah," and
cursing at 5:00 a.m. and saying, "Open
up the effing straight before mov."
I would like to see more people give you
credit for that because if you watch
your lectures, you you really spelled
out the asymmetrical warfare correctly,
the strategy that Iran is using about
the downfall of American empire being
hubris, which is so clearly why Trump is
making all these errors, why he thought
it was going to be another in Venezuela.
That's what I think we should talk
about.
>> Okay. Absolutely. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> But I also saw I mean personally, you
know, I I saw a lot of your fans were
saying that you were thinking about uh
stepping back. I saw you posted
something on Substack. Has it been
overwhelming? So, you've had a major a
major rise. I think uh obviously because
you got so much of this right, but
personally, how are things for you? I
was going to reach out and email you,
but I didn't. Maybe I should have.
Right. Yeah. So, March was really hard
because um when the war started February
28th, I couldn't sleep for two weeks
because I was so anxious um and afraid.
You know, I have three kids. I'm just
worried about the world that they will
inherit. Um and I was just following the
news for two weeks straight and my mind
was a beehive.
And um there were also some attacks
against me. There was clearly a smear
campaign that was coordinated because
certain influencers were using the same
talking points and using the same um um
uh it it seemed as as though they got
the same memo basically. But I really
didn't mind that. I was more concerned
about like where this war might go and
where this might might lead. It was
making me very anxious and um and then
you know a lot of people reached out um
and I was overwhelmed with med media
requests and I I had to turn a lot down
just because because I had just so many
commitments and I I want to like
maintain teaching my class and I reached
a point where I actually don't want to
do this. I don't want to be the center
of a storm. I don't want to be the
center of attention. Like what I
specialize in is doing deep analysis um
and trying to tie current events to
historical um patterns and try to um
offer some insight and clarity as to how
the future might reveal reveal itself.
And that's something I've been doing for
the past two years. That's something I
really enjoy doing. And in the
beginning, you know, when I was when I
was when I only had like, you know,
20,000 fans, um it was really rewarding.
was very edifying. Um, everyone was
really happy to have found me. It seemed
that as though it was a really small
club. Um, and everyone enjoyed being in
it. But then, as you know, this past
year, I became more and more prominent.
And then in March, I sort of blew up um,
everywhere. And that um, put me in the
eye of a sto of the storm. And and I
asked myself, the question I asked
myself is,
am I capable of still doing insightful
analysis
while being a celebrity of some sorts?
And and if the answer is no, then I
should stop being a celebrity and
continue doing uh research and teaching
because that's my value to the world.
That's what I should focus on. Um, and
so I was seriously considering just not
doing YouTube and taking some time off
and just trying to clear my head and
trying to get some perspective on what's
going on because I don't want to be
influenced by this attention. I I don't
want um to be a player in this game,
right? Um but you know as things moved
on um I recognized that the internet it
has no attention span you know it um you
know um and eventually people just shift
focus and so um and I was able to manage
my schedule more properly. So I so so um
my plan now is I want to continue
teaching until the end of semester when
my contract
um runs out and then I want to
um do more traveling to see more of the
world and hopefully do some lectures um
because I talk a lot about geopolitics
but I think it's very important to um
experience the world. So, I've been
invited by to a conference in Moscow in
late June. Um, and I'm really excited
about that because I've never been to
Russia, even though I talk a lot about
Russia. I would love to visit Japan at
some point because I've never actually
visited um Japan. Um, I I would like to
go to Europe um and I would like I would
like to go back to United States, visit
South America. So, um I really think
it's important for me to
um do more deep dive research and um I
want to continue to do my YouTube
because I built a very strong following
and they really enjoy learning from me.
I want to continue doing my Substack.
Um, at some point I want to switch gears
and write a book uh to really systemize
game theory um in a way that allows
people to start um um thinking uh in
terms of game theory themselves.
And yeah, so right now um I I I was in I
was in mid March pretty
um anxious, pretty depressed with the
state of affairs and I I felt that for
my mental health and for the sake of my
family, I should take some time off. Um,
but fortunately, I've been able to
manage a lot of the stress uh more
effectively. And so, I like to continue
doing what I'm doing, but at a much more
uh manageable schedule. So, basically
cut back on media requests, podcast
interviews, and maybe move like scale
down the teaching. Uh, before I was
uploading like three lectures a week,
and that uh was pretty unsustainable.
Um, so maybe in the future I'll move
towards one or two lectures a week. So
continue to update my community,
continue to educate my community, but
making sure that it's long-term
sustainable.
>> I'm happy to hear that. I was worried. I
was and I think I I didn't reach out
because I'm like, okay, you have it
figured out. There's But it uh I'm sure
you saw the attacks and you knew.
>> But yeah, we still want the lectures.
Three a week. That's a lot. You know,
since the war ramped up, we've been
uploading a lot. I was really surprised
at how much you were able to do because
it's recorded. It's an, you know, they
average of about an hour long, an hour
lecture. So, it must be a lot of
preparation, a lot of notes, and you do
it in one take, no cuts. And when I saw
that your mic cut off because, you know,
you probably all over the place. It was
I was worried you were going to you were
going to quit, but that that's good to
hear. Does it feel like you've been at
the start of this war in an ideological
war or a spiritual war?
Um yeah, I mean I I feel as though
um there's so much temptation to take
advantage of my celebrity, right? So a
lot of people have reached out and said,
you know, they want me to invite me to
do a lecture. Um people have invited me
to do a podcast and they'll pay for my
media appearance. Um um there are a lot
of people in China who've reached out
and they want to
um make me famous in China. Basically,
I'm not famous in China. I'm actually
more famous. It's really strange. I'm
actually more famous United States than
I than I'm in China. I purposely keep a
low profile.
>> So, I think my priority is um I can't
get distracted by any of this. Like I'm
very I've been very clear uh for the
longest time, these past few years, what
my mission is. My mission is to raise my
children and h to be good people and to
be a good role model to them. Um my
mission is to educate people to the best
of my ability. If you want to get
educated, I want to provide the best
education to you possible. And my
mission is to constantly learn about the
world to constantly um maintain my
curiosity, maintain my objectivity and
try to provide enlightenment uh to whom
humanity. Okay. So those are my three
major missions and this is something
that I set set out for myself a long
time ago when I started to have
children. Um and I want to maintain my
my mission. So, you know, I mean, I'm
I'm getting millions of views on YouTube
and, you know, I mean, I could easily
monetize it and retire a millionaire in
a few years, right? Um, but I don't want
to do that. I want to keep myself lean
and hungry. I I want to provide
restraints on myself. I I don't want to
make life easy for myself. I mean like I
I mean I I I want to maintain a very
disciplined uh rigorous lifestyle where
I'm forcing myself to be to be the best
I can be. Um so but you know at the same
time it's always like well you know I
mean you have three kids and you get
famous in China then they can go to the
best schools everyone will be nice to
them and they they have nothing to worry
about for the rest of their lives. And
honestly, if I were younger, if I if I'm
my 20s and 30s, I would easily give in
to all this temptation. But I've reached
a point in my in my life where um I
don't actually care anymore. I don't
really don't care about the wealth or
the status or the power or the fame. I
just know who I am and I know what I
want to do and I'm very focused on
achieving my my my mission. So yeah,
there is temptation. Um it is a
spiritual war, but but I feel feel as
though I'm very fortunate in that I've
reached an age where I can handle um all
the temptation pretty well and I've
reached an age where I have the maturity
and the perspective and experience to
know what matters and what is right.
>> You were I mean you got it right. the
all the media appearances that you've
been on, you were on the Tucker show,
you were on Piers Morgan, and on the
last uh appearance you had on my stream,
you mentioned how you thought the
Patrick BD David show was going to be a
setup. You got it spot on. They recently
posted a podcast and a video where they
were criticizing and they they were
saying that you were a fraud because of
that that clip obviously. Well, that was
showed that you predicted that attack
just like you predicted the attacks on
Iran. So were you
>> wait so so so
um I will be on his show tomorrow. I I
I've agreed to go on his show
>> because I feel it's important to engage
different perspectives.
>> Yeah.
>> Um so I was on the Medi Hassim show um
and you know he spent an hour sorry he
spent half an hour with me. I think 10
minutes of it was he was just lobbing um
crit criticisms accusations against me
and um it was not a pleasant experience.
I mean he's he's very aggressive and
he's very provocative.
>> Um but I felt that for my audience it
was good to see me in in in in sort of
in this sort of situation. It's it's
good that I'm not in a bubble and that
I'm willing to hear different
perspectives. And so I I think it's
important for me to confront my my
critics and to provide my um side of the
story. I I you know, we talked about
this last time, but I think the most
important thing is to be open-minded and
to engage people in good faith debate.
Some people may not may not have good
faith, but I think it's very important
to set the principle of it's really
important to engage in debate just for
your own self-learning. Remember last
time we spoke you were saying that a lot
of these debates or loud panels can be a
waste of time and it's better to sit
down with somebody you disagree with and
have a contentious conversation. But how
do you differentiate those loud debates
between a an exchange of ideas?
>> Right. So I mean um I think I think a
very quick limits test is how long is it
going to be? If it's 10 minutes, you
know, they're looking for sound bites. U
because I' I've been on TV before and I
I know what TV is like. they're looking
for, you know, the gotcha moment. Um,
but so David, um, um, Patrick that David
to his credit has given me two hours.
So, so we had two-hour conversation.
Um, and so I think I I have enough time
to elaborate on certain points that I
was not able to elaborate on say maybe
Piers Morgan because I was 15 minutes,
right? Um, and the other thing is how
many people are in this debate, right?
So you go on Paris Morgan the panel
there's like three or four four people
they're all they're all shutting over
one another and I don't really enjoy
that sort of thing. Um but I think with
um Patrick B David it it'll be me and
and his people.
>> I mean they have been pushing the war
quite a bit. I saw recently I don't know
if if Patrick was on it but they had
several of the other co-hosts they were
essentially saying that they want to
keep on escalating this conflict which
you've spelled out in your lectures was
it's just going to be a disaster. I like
what Joe Kent said. He said that they
should retreat and they should try to
negotiate and work with Iran to reopen
the trade of Formuz. There's no other
opportunity. It seems like they're
getting closer to a ground troop
invasion. So, if they keep making this
mistake and listening to people like I
don't know if you know Loomer, she's
saying that she wants the United States
to bomb all the mosques in Iran, I'm not
even exaggerating, to bomb their power
plants. It seems like that was just hit
and they are Iran's are refusing to
negotiate at all because they hit the
power plants and a lot of this is
straight up war crime. It doesn't even
seem like war crime has a real meaning
anymore because they are not going to
face pressure from the Geneva Convention
from the United Nations. They just get
away with it.
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, I I think Joe Kenn is
absolutely right. you know, if the
United States were to um just stop this
war and retreat, Iran would be perfectly
happy to go to negotiating table because
what what people forget is that there
are different factions within Iran as
well. there are many uh factions who
don't want this war to continue because
obviously um this will be devastating
for the civilians and um it's going to
take years and years to build back a lot
of infrastructure. So if the United
States were to retreat today and closer
Middle East bases, Iran would be
perfectly happy to negotiate a deal with
the United States where both would be
responsible for the sort of humus and
they would share tolls and terrors. I
guarantee you if the United States were
to say to Iran, "We're leaving. Let's
make a deal that benefits both of us,"
Iran would be like, "Absolutely." And
you know what, Iran would be like, "You
know what? If you want to come and
invest in our country, and if um um you
want us to join the USD system, uh if
you want us treasuries, we'd be happy to
do so. You know, just strike a deal like
like China did with u China in the '9s,
right? where China was given most
favorite nation uh trading status. You
had tons of American investment and
expertise flowing into the country. In
return, China started to buy a lot of US
treasuries. Iran would be more than
happy to make this deal. They'd be
ecstatic about making this deal. So the
big question is why not make this deal?
It's mutually beneficial. It's win-win.
It would bring peace to the world.
>> The art of the deal. But
>> the art of the deal. Yes.
>> We know. I mean, look, if you if you
watch uh predictive history, you you
could see that that's not going to
happen. This is the effect of
>> the hell is going to happen.
>> I mean, just look what Trump's saying. I
mean, this morning, that's what he
should do. That's obviously the only
outcome. It's going to be a disaster.
He is completely losing his mind. I
don't know if you think that he has some
cognitive issues going on. It seems like
a scenile old person. It's a straight up
disaster. And since the last time I
spoke to you, Pam Bondi has now been uh
fired. They're saying that she's going
to be repositioned to the private
sector. She's no longer attorney
general. Heath was question impressed
for firing eight top generals within the
military. It seems like although I mean
they they've been declaring victory for
4 weeks. I don't know what type of
victorious war this is. If nothing was
accomplished besides killing civilians,
the straight of horm is closed. Our
economy is up, oil's up, everything that
you have laid out in your lectures has
come true. And this is probably going to
keep being the disaster that it is. In
your last uh in the Pax Judeaic Arising
lecture, you were talking about how this
is probably going to be the decline of
American empire. Do you still hold that
position?
>> Yeah. Um, I absolutely do. I think this
is the end of American Empire. The thing
about war that people don't appreciate
because it's been a long time since we
fought a real war is that war makes
people crazy, right? It's like if you're
in a fight um and maybe um you didn't
mean to get in the fight and maybe maybe
in the beginning um the fight was over
the pitiest things and the observers
think, oh well, you know, let's just
argue and push each other and then punch
each other. But then but then um this
thing will stop. But once you're in the
fight, the adrenaline takes over, right?
You're and and you just want to win no
matter what. And you can do anything to
win. So what um what's happening is that
the American military, maybe they were
not in for this war, but now that that
they're in this war, they want to win
this war at all costs. Um, and
you look at guy like Peter Hexav
whenever he does a press conference, I
swear to God, it's almost like like like
he talks war in a as though he's having
an orgasm. I mean, do you get that
impression where like he just loves
this, right? When he says like
negotiating with bombs, it's like he's
climaxing.
>> Yeah.
>> Like like it's it's these people are
>> it's these people are insane. And I
think that's what war does to people.
You know, you go to World War I where,
you know, for years they were foring
millions of people to their deaths in
the trenches. They were ordering
millions of men um to go run into
machine gun fire. And you and then
you're you're like, why why would they
do that? That's that's irrational. But
you have to understand war makes people
crazy. So, as this thing progresses,
you're going to see more craziness, more
madness on the part of Trump and Hexavv.
I mean, Hexavv loves his thing. Um, and
then Trump is doesn't want to lose face,
right? He does he he he fears I mean,
the thing he fears most is humiliation,
being called a clown, being called
incompetent. Um, he's a very insecure
man. So, so I think that they would
definitely they're definitely going to
bomb power plants and they are going to
um definitely bomb dissolation plants
and they're definitely going to send in
ground troops. this thing will just
escalate and escalate and the problem is
that as this becomes much more crazy, as
this becomes much more mad,
the American people will become much
more desensitized to this madness and
eventually things become much more
normalized until America finds itself in
total war. And that's the real fear.
>> We already are desensitized so that the
war never happens on our soil.
>> We're so far away from these conflicts.
The vast majority of people I did a
interview or I talked to people in the
subway station. Most of them they are
following the idea of ignorance is
bliss. They just like I don't want to
read about it. And it's just in
comparison you think about the people in
Iran. They don't get to think that way.
It's not like I'm just going to turn my
brain off to it because it hurts my
feelings. They have to think about it
because it's life. But for us the great
tragedy is information. So it's the
desensitization that you could see in
America. It stretched to Gaza and around
the world. Americans getting more upset
about Harambe than they are about this
conflict. And I have been extremely
alarmed that we are so desensitized.
What I'm also realizing is you're
talking about the insanity of it and
Hegset saying that we negotiate with
bombs. He is treating it like it's a
video game. He talks about it and even
their marketing of this war is like an
80s action movie like it's Rambo or
Scarface, you know, posting golf edits
and it turns into a bomb.
>> They really do believe that this is
playing a video game in a way. I don't
think that they view it as human life at
all. If you look at the drone footage
that they're posting, it's as if they're
using an Xbox controller.
I've also I think a lot of people have
seen well because it's Easter that the
evangelical sect which doesn't represent
all Catholics and all Christians all
orthodox this specific to the
evangelical Christians Paula White
Trump's spiritual adviser what she's
doing you know blowing into the
microphone and getting people to do
exorcisms the fact that they're trying
to pray for this war and turning Trump
into an idol Trump is using you know
messiah like rhetoric what is the truth
about evangelical Christians how are Are
they so insane? Not all of them, but
they are using some really insane
rhetoric.
>> Well, you know what? Two two years ago
when I um was posting my my lectures to
YouTube, um I said there were there'll
be three major reasons for a US invasion
of uh Iran. And the three reasons were
number one Christian Zionist Zionism,
the evangelical evangelicals uh in in
America. Second was Saudi Arabia. And
the third is hubris empire. Right? So um
for me Israel is not a factor a large a
factor as people assume it to be. Um I I
think the Christian Zionists are much
larger problem.
>> Agree. And so for them, um, this war in
the Middle East is the fulfillment of
biblical prophecy, meaning that this
will eventually culminate with the
second coming and the return of Jesus
and the rapture. And um so if they if
they can um
um provoke events in a certain way then
they it will cause a domino effect a
chain uh reaction which will lead to the
end of the world right and so um the
certain conditions they have to meet is
um one is a war in the Middle East which
is happening right now. Uh second is the
destruction of the alactic mosque and
the building of the third temple. Uh
this will happen I think with next two
years. It will happen very very soon and
I think it's going to shock people. Um
if you don't believe that this war is
esquetological or religious in any way
when the Alex mos is destroyed I
guarantee you you you will you will
start to believe this is a religious
war. Um anti-semitism is actually a very
important part of a puzzle as well
because they need the Jewish diaspora to
return to uh Israel and then uh you have
the uh Jewish Messiah, the coming of the
Jewish Messiah. Um and then you have the
war of Gog and Maul. Okay, so you have
these you you have you need to have
these different elements in place. So it
seems as though there's a script in
place and there are
um fundamentalists um just crazy
religious extremists on um and and you
know they they're occupy different
countries right so you have these
Zionists in Israel but then you have the
Christian Zionist in America um and
they're all working towards the the same
goal and and I I don't think people
espec es especially young people
appreciate the appeal
of this esquetology.
Um it's it's almost like a drug it
because it's a way to structure your
life and give it meaning and purpose,
right? You're just trying to achieve one
goal and it's a script. So you all you
have to do is play your your part, you
know, speak one or two lines in the
script and the script will move um um
automatically uh naturally almost
divinely um towards the um end of the
world and the and the coming return the
return of Jesus. Um, and people don't
appreciate how powerful this movement is
because if you look at the stats, okay,
about a quarter, one/4 of Americans are
evangelicals. Okay, most are not
Christian Zionist. So maybe maybe about
10% are Christian Zionist. But then
you're talking about like at least in
America 10 to 20 30 million people who
are Christian Zionists. Okay, that's a
lot of people because remember, not only
do they believe this stuff, but they're
actively contributing
and acting towards achieving this
vision, which means that they're
donating money to this cause. So, um
there's a pastor named John [ __ ] H A
Ge, and he runs an organization called
Christians United for Israel. It's about
7 million people. They have 7 million
people in this group. And what they
specialize in is fund raising funds to
fund West Bank settlement. Okay. So
these are the people driving a lot of
the conflict in the Middle East because
because they want the Jews to return to
Israel
um which would initiate a chain of
events that would lead to the return of
Jesus. So they do fundraising but also
they will also work for the government.
They'll lobby politicians.
If you speak out against Israel, these
people will call you up every single day
and batter you and they'll go to the
office and protest you. Okay? So, these
people um they may not have that much
money, but they certainly are willing to
work their ass off in order to achieve
their vision and they're united and they
have the same purpose. And then you
combine this with Apac money, right? The
Apac people and all these Jewish Zionist
billionaire money and they become like
an unstoppable political force in
America. Mhm. Since we last spoke, Alaka
mosque was closed for Eid prayer. I
think it was the first time since 1967.
It's also been closed for 35 days. And I
was leaving Saudi. Originally, I had to
cancel it because of the war. I was
going to go to Medina with a big group
for Ramadan. Had to be cancelled, but I
ended up going anyway. And on the way
back, I was in the Istanbul airport.
It's a huge international airport. And I
saw this giant screen playing the news
and it showed that they were reporting
Israel was reporting that Iran's debris
from missiles was firing near near Alaka
mosque in Jerusalem. So it's that seems
like the that's the playbook. You know
the division that you see between the
Persians and Arabs, it seems like there
is some Sunni Shia conflict. They were
probably going to try to pin it similar
to, you know, if you can make a
comparison to 9/11 there. will probably
try to pin it on Iran and say that they
are the ones responsible for bombing
Alakamos even though it's a holy site
for Sunni an it's the the third holy
city Jerusalem and Alakam mo is the
third most important mosque in the world
why was it closed and some people are
speculating that it could be because
MSD's planting bombs there is there a
specific reason
>> look so um I you you look at what's
happening what's been happening these
past few years And it's pretty clear
what the playbook is. Okay. So, um, many
years ago, this Texas farmer,
um, he breded perfect red heers, right?
And then he and it cost him millions of
dollars to bre uh, uh, breed perfect red
hers. And you need them as a sacrifice
to consecrate the grounds for the
building of the third temple. And then
he flew them to Israel. And so now
there's like uh they're all in Israel.
They're all perfect. They're they're all
ready to be sacrificed when the time is
appropriate. Okay, that's number one.
Number two is that there's there's
organization in Israel called the Jewish
uh sorry the temple institute. The
temple in Institute they have a website
and what they've done is they have
already built brick by brick the third
temple. Okay. So the third temple is
already built and all they to do is move
it into position when uh the dome of the
rock is destroyed because the dome of
the rock is uh where the third temple
has to be. Um that's number two. Number
three is u for the past few years
they've been conducting archeological
digs under Alex the Alex complex. Now
why would you do that? And the answer
is, well, because you plan you plan to
plant bombs to do a control demolition.
Last June, there was a prominent Israeli
rabbi who told his followers, "Oh my
god, this war, this 12-day war,
it was a perfect opportunity to do a
false flag where we pretend an Iranian
missile hits the Alexic mosque. we blow
it up and they control demolition and
then um the Persians and the Arabs
because they're are animals start
killing each other and then we have
peace in the Middle East. Right? So it
seems as though all the ingredients are
in place. All the elements are in place.
And what I think they're waiting for is
this. What I think they're waiting for
is global economic collapse. And this
could happen in the next 6 months,
right? when East Asia is completely out
of oil and you and you um have total uh
lockdowns like COVID um where in Africa
people people are starving because they
don't have fertilizer anymore. In the
United States, people are riding uh
because of inflation, because of the
national draft, whatever. But when the
entire world is chaos, no one's gonna
notice
the Alex Moss has been destroyed,
>> right? And I think they're waiting for
that. They're very patient. They're very
methodical. I think you we will see this
happen all all this play out in the next
year year or two.
>> Have you noticed a shift in the strategy
to prevent this information from
spreading? because any sort of basic
analysis and you can understand what the
objective is. Before several years ago,
this sort of information would have been
censored everywhere. I noticed now that
I I I spoke to an American soldier on
stream and I was telling him about the
war, what's really happening. He's like,
I just want to defend my country. Well,
Rubio said that they did not pose a
threat and they preemptively attacked
Israel to prevent an attack. They were
defending themselves by striking first.
And he started saying that, okay, well,
I want to protect God's chosen people.
I'm a Christian. And I'm telling him,
okay, well, there's the similarity
between Muslims and Christians. We both
believe Jesus is the Messiah. Most
Israel, well, not all, not most, but
many believe that Jesus is burning in
hell. Why would you die for these
people? Even when you tell people this,
they still believe in their programming.
Is this the new strategy? Have they
realized that they won the propaganda
war so they don't need to censor?
Um so I think that what's happening now
is very different from what happened
during co right uh because remember in
the first few um weeks of co there there
was huge suspicion that this was a lab
leak um and there were a lot of
criticisms that these lockdowns won't
work and we shouldn't trust the vaccines
and there's a massive campaign to answer
anyone and everyone who raised any
questions about co That's why I was
banned on YouTube for that reason.
>> Right. Right. And today we're seeing the
complete opposite where
very prominent influencers such as
yourself, such as Carlson are given huge
microphones and are allowed to say
whatever they want against this war. You
have a lot of Americans who are now
rooting for Iran because they they
understand how unjust this war is. I'm
being amplified in uh throughout social
media. I don't think it's organic. I I I
I I think like I'm being amplified uh
and and given more prominence than I
than I I should be.
>> And so the question is why is this
happening?
>> And one suspicion I have is that this
sort of social descent,
this social division is also part of the
playbook. Um because if they if this war
is meant to move towards
uh the end of the world and the great uh
reset then you need civil war throughout
the western world, right? You need civil
war in America. You need civil war in
Europe. And what better way to ferment
civil war to have people argue all the
time
>> on social media? Uh what better way than
to um uh show people that this war is
pointless, it's unwinable.
Um and just so um apathy and discontent
in in in the American mind. So I mean I
mean I I don't I don't I don't know if
this is true but but I think that if we
just assume that this war is
esquetological
and there are many powerful people who
benefit from the great reset then civil
war is part of the script.
>> Mhm. I've been trying to advocate for
unity as much as I possibly can
>> and I'm sure you felt it and I think
it's part of the coordinated attack on
you. so many people that should ally
with you and understand what you're
talking about. I'm seeing them lash out
at you so angrily and I'm
>> it's confusing.
>> Also, with the rise of these AI accounts
on X and you half of the replies on my
Twitter, it's just straight up people
talking about my faith and my race and
person. It's just and it's like that
they have notifications on. You click on
the profile, it doesn't even look real.
And it is demoralizing. I think that
they shifted from censorship to
demoralization because it it's draining.
That's why I asked you about spiritual
warfare because that will really it is
probably why you felt like you were
having a mental health problem in Marsh
because all of that is not normal for
one human to process.
>> Yes. Yeah. No, listen. Um, there are
certain individuals that before I highly
respected
and I thought that they would be on my
side completely. So, one person that
comes to mind is David Ike. I'm not sure
if you come across Yeah.
>> his work.
>> That was about like
>> and like I've said very nice things
about David Ike in the past. I think
he's been very courageous
>> in um trying to promote his ideas even
though I don't really agree with some of
his ideas. is I agree with most of his
ideas but I disagree with some aspects
of of his ideas but that's just normal
right two intelligent person they might
be sympathetic towards each other um
they might have share similar viewpoint
but they have some disagreements on
certain issues and he's been vindicated
so many times right because he was one
of the first to promote the idea that
the elite are this transnational cabal
of pedophiles right and he's been proven
right so many times and when I blew up.
He was one of the first to attack me
saying that I'm basically a useful
idiot. I'm I'm I'm like working for the
global cult to show discontent and so
confusion among the people. and he's
been consistent about it and it's been
really surprising for me because again
we will agree D Ike and I if we were to
sit down we would agree on like 9% of
everything and we might disagree on is
there really a global cult um are there
really inter interdimensional lizard um
people I mean we might disagree on
certain aspects but on the most part
like the general trend how the world
works we would we would get along very
very well and he's been very hostile
towards me and he's been very hostile
towards Tucker Carlson for whatever
reason because Tucker Carlson has been
the most consistent anti-war voice in
America for the past five six years and
so it's very strange. I find Patrick bad
David also very strange because five
years ago or four years ago during co
like I I I would have loved to be on a
show and we we would we we would have
like shown how uh co was clearly a lab
leak clearly it was a boweapon clearly
these lockdowns um or authoritarian
measures uh clearly you shouldn't take
the vaccine uh we would have agreed on
DEI we would have agreed on world
politics we would have agreed on a lot
of issues and before I was watching a
lot and then this Israel thing happens
and for whatever reason he's very
pro-Israel, pro-war, and he attacks me.
Um, and and and so I just find this
really weird.
>> I've seen it outside of uh geopolitics.
I saw David Ike. That one was confusing.
He has been critical of Alex Jones and I
could see how that makes sense because
Alex Jones was probably one of the most
important Trump influencers, but I like
that he saying the right things now. So,
I was very
>> y skeptical of Alex for a while, but I
like that he's changed his opinion and I
think he's saying the right things now.
But David like that one is really I was
gonna bring him on. I invited him to
come on the stream. I was going to ask
him about that because it doesn't make
sense. But outside of politics, I've
seen it with faith, too. I think a lot
of people I don't think it's paid. I
really think this is the product of
social media and their new strategy
>> because people are attacking their own
group. I'm seeing a lot of Muslims turn
against each other. You know, people,
oh, okay, I live in Dubai, you're
supporting Iran, and then you have so
much infighting. People, you know,
especially within the Islamic world,
usually the Muslims are some of the most
united people. And, you know, small
disagreements people are hyperfixating
on and arguing with each other. And I'm
telling them and reaching out to them,
this is such a minor thing that you
should not be focusing your energy on,
but I really think people are are
wrapped up in that new propaganda
strategy of hatred.
>> You you know, one thing that might be
interesting is maybe you could set up a
conversation uh between uh me and David
Ike, you know, invite both of us on on
on your stream and try to figure out
what's going on because I see him as a
teacher. you know, for the past uh few
decades, he's gone out of his way to
educate and enlighten the general public
about how the world really works. I see
myself in a similar vein. So, I think we
have a similar vision. We have a similar
outlook. And I don't understand why we
have disagreements because I mean,
unlike Alex Jones, I'm not partisan,
right? I never said, you know, vote for
Trump and Trump's going to save the
world. I I mean, like like what I said
was Trump's going to start the stupid
war that's going to destroy the American
empire. Um, so I I mean like I don't see
myself as partisan. I don't see myself
as political. I see myself as a teacher
who's trying to teach um people how to
think for themselves. And I think that's
something that David like is doing doing
as well. So I'm completely confused as
to why he consist he consistently
attacks me. Um so I would love to have a
conversation with with him if that's
possible.
>> Invite is open. I think uh I'm happy to
set that up with David. A lot of it too
I I think you're right. the war makes
people insane and he sets the way he's
like p we're gonna pound him. We're
gonna we're gonna keep up Trump like
raising his eyebrows. But equally, I
think a lot of people that have been
speaking about this for a long time are
becoming bitter because it's like, okay,
everything that I've been saying I'm now
vindicated about, right? There's been
people that have been critical of Trump
and of Isra especially, I think
anti-Israel critics are now looking at
what's happening. It's just, you know,
then you get angry. There's a lot of
jealousy in the air like, "Oh, he has
more followers." It's just made people
lose that sense of humanity, you know,
because now that you're seeing
everything that you was predicted
spelled out in front of your eyes, what
are you going to talk about on your show
that you're just going to lash out to
people within your circle? So, and you
mentioned about Larry Frink and Black
Rockck, and I saw I think you mentioned
that in one of your most recent
lectures. So, Larry Frink, the CEO of
Black Rockck
spelled out his new strategy as well.
It's kind of similar. He's saying that
he's wants to invest money more on war
propaganda essentially rather than
pushing woke ideology. And the question
he was posed was wokeism is a failed
project. So I think a lot of people like
the liberals for example are very
critical of Trump and they always
protest the billionaire class. It is
funny to see them maybe start to realize
if they see this interview that so much
of their ideology, you know, the blue
hair and all these isms and all these
genders, this was pushed specifically by
the same ones that you protest,
>> a Zionist billionaire who wants to keep
you divided. Have they given up on
pushing DEI and wokeism?
>> Yeah. So David Ike makes this point and
he's absolutely right in that wisdom was
a direct response to Occupy Wall Street
because because remember 2008 people
were pissed because they found out that
the financial industry were just a bunch
of criminals who didn't know what they
were doing who were incompetent but who
control all the levels of power so they
could bail themselves out while screwing
over everyone else. Right? So you start
this huge movement called Occupy Wall
Street that transcended all class
divisions, all racial divisions. And um
it was a great movement. It was it was a
great um um slogan, right, against 1%
like you know, let's let's unite against
1%. And I think the powers that be were
generally generally horrified by this.
In fact, Hillary Clinton talked about
this how, you know, we we can't have
this happen where uh the people align
against the banking interests because
quite honestly um this is a very this
could be a very powerful political
movement. So their strategy then was to
promote um DEI to so um descent and
discord and and say like no what matters
that class. Okay, that doesn't really
matter. What matters is race. That's
what matters, you know, and like we
should focus on the fact that black
uh brown uh women um gay were all
historically uh persecuted. And that's
what we should be concerned about. We
should we should be concerned about
addressing his historical grievances
rather than than about wealth
redistribution. Right? And so and and so
this was promoted throughout uh American
society, especially in the universities
and it's been a disaster for America.
Um, and it was completely irrational
and and and the thing is that it worked
and it it's made young people impossible
to reason with.
>> Like why are we concerned about racial
issues when no one can actually afford a
living wage? Should not should not be
our concern.
>> Uh let's not worry about things that
divide us. Let's let's focus on things
that unite us, which is our mutual
hatred for the banking elite, for all
these bankers that bankrupt America and
then laugh about it, right? And and they
still got their huge bonuses at the end
at the end of the year. So, and and now
what what they realize is that, well,
no, well, DI is a problem because it
also leads to protest against the
genocide in Gaza, right? So now we we
need to change tax and um and yeah.
>> Yeah, you're right. People, not just
people on the left who fell for this
Black Rockck programming, but on the
right wing, too. I I tweeted saying that
the first racist was Satan. I don't know
if you know the the story of Satan. You
definitely do. And he was rejecting the
command to prostrate to Adam and because
he thought that he was well, at first he
was an angel, angel Gabriel. And because
he thought he was superior, he refused.
And then he ended up becoming Satan. So
that is an act of superiority. That's uh
that's the arrogance, that's pride,
that's the same as racism. And so many
people got really upset with that idea.
I thought, you know, there's a
difference between making jokes about
race and actually harboring racist
ideology. And I was surprised to hear
that because this is the problem with
Israel. It's a superiority complex. Look
at the Epstein files. the way he's
speaking about the goyam, it comes from
this belief that you have something
special within your DNA that makes you
better than others. So to focus on what
is is really important now is crucial.
But I think a lot of people are
shifting. I don't know if you've noticed
this, but many people who used to
classify themselves as Democrat or
Republican, as left or right or liberal,
this stuff, I think people have realized
slowly that a lot of this is preventing
you from seeing the bigger picture. And
it's really about right and wrong, not
left and right.
>> Have you um come across a woman named
Robin D'Angelo? I
>> have not.
>> You know who she is? Okay. So, um, Robin
D'Angelo
wrote a book called White Fragility,
and what she promotes is the idea that
all white people are born racist.
And this racism is the source of all
evil in the world. And what what white
people need to do is engage in a series
of self-reflections, basically seminars
where you pay her to come to you and
teach you how to be anti-racist.
And these seminars are expensive, man.
Like like like just Google her. She is
just loaded. Um, and so she's organizing
seminars where these white ser urban
women come and listen to her tell them
how racist they are and how evil they
are. And they just they just, you know,
lap it up. They just love this. And the
other thing that's really confusing is
there's no black person
in these seminars. In fact, there's a
strict prohibition against black people
participating in these seminars. Now,
you would think that if you want to
reduce your racism, you would engage
people who are different from you to
learn that they are just like you, like
to learn empathy, right?
But
these seminars strictly strictly demand
that the races be kept be kept separate
from each other. Uh um because
apparently
uh blacks have historically been
persecuted and victimized. So we can't
put blacks in a room of white wealthy
suburban women who would persecute them
even more. So we have to protect the
black people like basically put them in
a zoo. Okay, it's important we put put
back black people in a zoo so we can
look at them and say, "Oh my god, how
terrible these black people have to
suffer under racism." Okay, but you
don't you don't you can't touch them.
You can't feed them. Okay, you you can't
interact with them. So, this Robin
Angelo is like the worst person in
America. She uh gets rich by um
appealing to the idea of self
victimization
and she's a cult leader DEI at the end
of the day. Okay, if you just like watch
her speak, she is a cult leader. No
different from people like Alon Hubard
from she well first of all she's very
charismatic. Uh she's a great speaker.
Uh, but if you just like look at her
deme demeanors, if you look look at her
speech, if you listen to her logic,
she's a cult leader.
>> Yeah, I was looking up her her Wikipedia
just now. I wanted to see, but it
doesn't list in the early life what I
was looking for. Uh, I made a mistake.
It's not Angel Gabriel, my mistake. It's
uh, Angel became Satan. People are
getting upset.
>> Right. Right.
>> So, basically, this is all nonsense.
White people aren't born inherently
racist. This is a se a lot of these
seminars too. You could saw it post
George Floyd and BLM. White people had
so much guilt over the protest going on
that they would start to prostrate to
black people and recreate slavery and
they would let black people whip them.
But
what do you think is there any validity
in this? Where do you think white
supremacy
is important today? How is this an
important issue to talk about today? And
how does it relate at all to the
supremacy we see in Israel?
>> Um so America has always had um an issue
of racism u because America is a melting
pot right? So if you go back to the um
19th century, the late 19th century,
the real concern was genetics because
these Catholics were coming into the
country, right? These Catholics from
Poland, Ireland, Italy and they and
Catholics were having kids, the
Protestants
uh were not having kids and so they
started the eugenics movement like which
led to Planned Parenthood. uh but the
idea is that we need to maintain the uh
integrity and the sanctity of the gene
pool. So we need to basically neuter
these immigrants and prevent them have
from having kids while encouraging the
Protestants uh the Ramens to have more
more kids. And so this has has been a
concern uh going back to the um late
19th century when immigration was
starting to flood the the country. And
you know the Nazis used the American uh
um um thinking the um American
sterilization program, American eugenics
program. Uh they they basically just
copied everything from from America. Um
and um and and so this has been a
consistent uh issue. But what I'll also
say is that I've been to a lot of
countries in the world and I would say
that America is probably the least
racist country in the world. Uh because
regardless of
uh America's racist past, Americans have
deep respect for hard work and for
talent. America is the only country in
the world where you can come as a nobody
and work really hard, open a restaurant
and be a millionaire. And and I know
because my relatives have done so. Um
and you couldn't do that in China. You
couldn't do that in Europe. You couldn't
do that anywhere else. Um so yeah, I
understand that there is a racist past
in America. There there's a pass of
slavery. Uh there's a pass of genocide
against the indigenous people. I
understand that. But at the same time,
we can't forget that America is still
probably the most open and generous
society in the world.
>> Do you think that there's any sort of
validity in the confusion of racism when
you look at Epstein? Because I'm
wondering how so many people like Gates,
like Trump, why were they able to get
along with somebody like Epste and see
him as a friend and see him as one and
the same? But then you see rhetoric very
recently from Trump where he's calling
Somalians low I or Somali's low IQ.
Is this some sort of subversion? How do
these wealthy influential people who
should be highly intelligent get so
easily subverted by an epsene?
>> Um so I think with Epstein it's not
racism, it's about bloodlines. So if
you're are part of that that circle of
people like like the top elite okay
you're really concerned about blood
bloodlines and the reason why is that
you need to explain in your mind why you
have all this power all this money
because objectively
um Bill Gates is it Bill Gates has like
billions of dollars right so he's like a
thousand times wealthier than us normal
people, but he's like a thousand times
smarter. Probably not. Um, and he he
sort of understands that. Okay. So, one
thing that they're trying to um look at
is
is my bloodline different? Do I come
from a race of the divine? Right? Am I
an ancestor of a Hercules or Achilles?
Right? Because back back in um the Greek
world, kings claim a divine bloodline
where you know their mother was raped by
Zeus or maybe uh their father was
Hercules uh a son of Zeus. So for the
elite bloodline is very very important
and they're constantly proving that how
they're descended from like the most
powerful people emperors um right so um
if you look at Epstein's emails one
thing that he was very obsessed with is
family heritage where he was having a
conversation with um uh Arendrene de
Rothschild you know um um who was member
of the Rothschild
And one thing that he told her is look
there were three families that were very
powerful in Europe, Jewish banking
families. Um they were the Rothschilds,
the Epsteines and the Gutmans and we um
built uh a shelter and Hitler lived in
the shelter for a long for a long time
and he he was obsessed with this
heritage of his proving to himself and
to others that the Epstein is one of the
most powerful families in the world.
They're part of the Illuminati. They're
they're up with the up there with the
Rothschilds. So, this is the this is
what the elite is just obsessed with,
proving to themselves in the world that
um they're just divine
>> and that's why they rule because because
it's not because of their brilliance.
It's not because of their ability. It's
not because of their leadership skills.
It's because they're divine. Their blood
is just different from ours. Mhm. And
again, that's why you see Kier Starmer
and Trump have something in common. Both
of their uh they have children that
married into similar families. Kushner
and then Kier Starmmer again, you know
who his wife is and who his children
are. But then why on the topic of
racism? Right now, Lebanon has been
invaded illegally and there's the
reports are that there's a million
displaced Lebanese people. It's
escalating. Hezbollah has struck back
quite a bit in the south of Lebanon. a
lot of missiles. But when these churches
are getting attacked and priests are
getting attacked, you don't see anybody
really talking about it in America. It
is Easter Sunday today. Why do you think
so many Americans turn a blind eye to
attacks on Christians in Lebanon?
Because they have an idea that Middle
Eastern countries are out of people are
all Muslim. Lebanon is has a very strong
Christian population, but people here
don't care.
Well, I mean, let's go back to the no
kings protest which I think happened um
a week a couple couple weeks ago, but
there's this huge protest, right? The no
kings
>> directed by Zionist in DC, a billionaire
family,
>> right? So So you were allowed to protest
no kings, which I don't I don't even
know what that means, no kings, because
America doesn't have a king, but you
were not allowed to protest the war in
Iran.
>> All right? if you were protesting war in
Iran, security would come and arrest you
or take you away. Um, so and so it's
just a sillious thing where you have
this global no kings movement. Um, you
have no no kings movement in Canada,
which is absurd because Canada does have
a king. You had the no kings movement in
Britain, which is absurd because Britain
does have a king, but and you have no
kings movement in in America. Um, and
no one knew what they were they they
were what what their platform was. No
one knew what their agenda was. And so
another question then is in 2003 during
the Iraq war there were huge protests
around the world against the war. There
are no protests today. So you wonder how
much of life today is organic.
>> Yeah. How much of it is uh people
actually express expressing their views
as opposed to they're being paid to
protest or they're being paid to promote
a certain viewpoint uh online. Um I I
think people don't appreciate the amount
of brainwashing indoctrination that goes
on in social media in daily life. Um and
and I think that
co was crucial because co taught the
elite not only that people can be
programmed to be obedient but also how
to program them. So you know co was this
massive uh experiment in mass political
indoctrination and they're still using
the same uh playbook today. Um and and
and and you're right. Why aren't we
protesting this war in Iran? Why aren't
we um protesting the what Israel is
doing in Lebanon? Why aren't we
protesting the fact that Israel seems to
be targeting everyone? Why why hasn't
anyone posted the fact that America at
the first day of the war killed the
leader of Iran which is against
international law and also um killed 168
innocent school girls. Why are there any
protests against that? So all this is
really weird. I'm wondering uh well I
want to ask you after but I want to
figure out what are these methods
because look back at six years ago the
George Floyd protests happened because
they saw this video of George Floyd.
Derek Chovvin was on putting a knee on
his back or neck and then the entire
country quite literally lights up in
flames. They're burning target. They're
burning police stations. Everybody's
protesting amidst the quarantine where
literally the day before people were
wiping down their groceries and their
Uber Eatats orders with the Clorox wipe.
The next day they see George Floyd and
everybody goes outside, breaks the
quarantine and forgets about social
distancing, forgets about being afraid.
The social programming was so effective
and you're right, I think they did
realize that. You would think,
especially LA 6 years ago when that
happened, that if you saw the release,
the partial release of the Epstein files
that there would be national uproar and
there's nothing. You would think that if
there was a war in Iran after bragging
about no new wars, saying that we're not
going to make the same mistakes that
there would be uprising all over the
country. Maybe part of it is that it's
majority youth that protests like the
Vietnam War. You see these college
protests, the college students that were
protesting against the genocide in Gaza,
a lot of them they got their student
visas revoked or they'd be punished by
the university. But outside of that, how
do you think that they're able to
manipulate and put the population under
mass psychosis? Because Trump even just
bragged about, I think yesterday, the
day before, that he was the one arming
the protesters in Iran for the 40,000
innocent civilians they keep talking
about. First it was 30,000. Then Trump
in this speech last week says it was
45,000 protesters. I'm seeing some
people say it was 90,000 now, but then
he says essentially what Mike Pompeo
said the day it happened that CIA was
arming these protesters to create mass
chaos. How is this so effective? How can
almost 8 billion people be controlled by
such a small few?
>> Yeah, that's a great question. So, I
have a theory. Okay. Um, so my theory is
that the people who are doing this are
not the elite. The people who are doing
this uh engaging social control are the
liberal intellectual class. Okay. So,
so, so, so let me explain. So, 1950s
there's a very popular book called the
power elite by C. right mills and he's
trying to explain how American power
works and he makes this argument which
is like the people at the very top okay
the people who at the very top of
industry finance politics they don't
really care
um they're just indifferent
people who really care are the 10% not
the 1% but the 10% the 10% are
journalists are teachers are professors
are doctors they are the in intellectual
class who control public opinion who
control uh the public narrative and on
one hand they think they are the powers
that be because they they are the
influencers um they are um the the
curators of public opinion but on the
other hand they know all their power
comes from the association with the
power elite. Okay. So on one hand they
are uh the ones that who who they so on
one hand they believe that they have all
the power but on the other hand in their
in their heart instinctively they
understand that their power comes from
loyalty to the real powers that be the
generals the uh financiers the begging
interests the politicians okay so um for
the longest time as America be was very
wealthy there was a an agreement between
the power elite and the intellectual
class and that the intellectual class
would be the check and balance on the
power elite so that they could balance
each other out and create um a fair and
open democratic society, right? And and
so for example during Vietnam war when
the power elite was engaging in this
suicidal
uh war of extermination in Vietnam um
the power elite still allowed the
intellectuals to protest. This is what
led to the Pentagon papers and the
publication of the Pentagon papers in
Washington Post and New York Times.
That's what forced the war to come to an
end. Okay. and what a conrite on CBS
news also opposed this war and that's
what led to eventually uh the turning of
public public opinion. So there's this
balance right and and for C white Mills
that's how America works at the at the
very top you have the 1% with all all
the money power uh but then you have the
10% which uh supports the system but
which also balances the system to make
it more democratic.
Then the problem though is 2016 Donald
Trump won
and now the intellectual class have fear
and anxiety because they see Donald
Trump as representing a populist
revolution. And if there's something
that the intellectual class really hate,
it's when the people become uppidity.
>> When they refuse to listen to mainstream
news. when they read the New York Times
and say, "This is BS, man."
>> When their high school teacher no longer
has authority over them, they see Donald
Trump as the existential threat to their
way of life. And that's why they all
rallied against him, right? And and
that's why um you had TDS. TDS is not
like people have became deranged about
Donald Trump and they're they became
irrational. It's more like they
understand that Donald Trump represents
a public revolution.
Uh and Donald Trump if his revolution
were to succeed then they would lose
their way of life because their bosses
the power elite would lose the power.
Okay. And then you had um COVID happened
which destroyed a lot of the economy and
um the industrial class benefited from
CO because well they could just sit at
home and do nothing all day while the
workers had to they were called
essential workers right they they still
had had to do do their job. So it taught
the intellectual class that okay it's
great to be an intellectual because you
don't really have to do any work but at
the same time it's also precurious. It's
also unstable uh because it's because
now because of co people recognize that
if you if you just stay at home all day
and do your work your your work is
probably worthless. Okay, I'm sorry to
say this, but if you are a professor and
you can just sit at home and lecture to
your students and your students only
even have to pay attention to to you.
Then you're then why do we need
colleges? Okay. And now you have AI and
the AI revolution. It's not about
replacing blue collar workers. You can't
do that. You're about it's about
replacing white collar workers, the
lawyers, the accountants, the doctors,
the professors, the high school
teachers. Right? So now you have this
entire industrial class that knows that
there's this popular populist revolution
um rising. They know that AI can replace
them. They know that people know that
they're worthless. So what do they do?
They um uh coales
uh together and they try their very best
to control public opinion because that's
the only value right. If they are not
able to control public opinion, then
they are absolutely worthless and
they're discarded by AI. They're
discarded by the power elite and uh
they're sacrificed, right? So that's why
they're working overtime to try to
control the public discourse as much as
possible. That's why you have the
promotion of DEI, transgenderism,
uh throughout schools because that
that's a way to brainwash kids into um
obedience. Okay, so that's my theory.
We're seeing it spelled out now. The
MAGA cult, which is similar to Robin
D'Angelo, who you just referenced with
racism. The Trump supporters now, they
were all anti-war last year. They were
all saying that if another Middle
Eastern conflict happened, they wouldn't
support. They said the worst thing that
could possibly happen for the American
Empire would be a ground troop invasion.
Then they all adjust. The same exact
people that were against this have now
found new justifications because they
put their loyalty completely into this
ideology. And I I really can't
understand how it happens if a lot of
these people are paid. But some of them
just want to die on this hill perhaps. I
I I can't figure it out. But they are
willing to sacrifice everything they
believe in to support this cause. And
there's a quote from Trump where he says
almost word for word that smart people
hate me. smart people don't that
intellectual class the ones that
understand what he's doing and that's
why Trump campaigns and why he's so
successful and what they call the Bible
belt or where he can convince people in
rural towns that he's one of them. So
many of the workingclass Americans, the
truck drivers, they are convinced that
Trump is like them. even though he's
literally sitting in what looks like a
gold throne, one of the first presidents
to not even be in DC, living in Mara
Lago, this palace with these, you know,
these eyes wide shut like parties. I
don't know if it's uh if it goes deeper,
maybe there's some sort of literal
hypnosis going on, but it it it really
is crazy to to witness firsthand.
>> Yeah. So, I'll tell you I'll tell you a
story, right? So 1992 there was this
election um contest between George HW
Bush and Bill Clinton and I just assumed
HW Bush would win it easily because
first of all it's very hard to unseen
incumbent president. Second second of
all Bush had just won this very popular
Persian Gulf War. Um his popular ratings
were skyhigh. Okay. And what happened
was that first of all Ross Perau came
into the race which sort of split off
the the conser conservative vote. The
other thing is that during one of these
debates between Bill Clinton, Ross
Burrow and um uh George George Bush
George Bush during the debate he looked
at his watch
and this was captured live on national
TV. you're in a debate
um deciding the fate of the country and
like I can't be bothered. I have to go
somewhere. Okay. And and that's what
what probably lost him the the race and
people just thought that this was just
the worst politician in the world. But
people don't remember something really
important about that election which is
that Bill Clinton and George HW Bush go
way back. They were very good friends.
In fact, George HW Bush saw Bill Clinton
as a prodigy. They met during Iran
Contra because George HW Bush was
basically the de facto leader of the of
Iran Contra. He he was the one um uh
controlling uh this deal. And then Bill
Clinton was governor of Arkansas at that
time and Arkansas was a really important
hub for Iran Contra. Um, so they they go
way back and then you're like, okay, but
why would George HW Bush purposely lose
election to Bill Clinton? And the reason
why is this, at this time in history,
uh, George HW Bush was trying to promote
NAFTA. Um, he was trying to promote free
trade with China. And people forget
this, but the Democrats were a
workingclass party,
dead set against NAFTA, dead set against
uh trade with China because because of
China's human rights record. And Bill
Clinton during the campaign campaigned
as a populist
promising
um that um he would not allow most fian
most favored nation uh trading status
with China. uh promising he would he
won't do NAFTA and then he gets elected
and he does the complete opposite and he
destroys the Democratic party from
within under Bill Clinton his eight
years Democratic party shifts from a
party of the working class to the party
of the coastal professional elite which
is still it is still today okay
>> so that's how politics work right so
there's no way George HB could have
promoted all these these um neoliberal
reforms, but Bill Clinton could, right?
So, going back to to to today where
there's no way Joe Biden would could
have launched a war against Iran because
the MAGA people would have gone up in
arms, right? You would have he would
have like rides in the streets, right?
>> But Donald Trump can. Okay.
>> I'm wondering uh not to harp on this
forever, but it's just it's so confusing
from your perspective growing up in you
mostly grew up in China, correct? Not in
Canada. No, I actually grew up in
Canada. Okay. So, so I was six when I
went over to Canada and and that's where
I grew up and then I went to Yale for
about four years. Then then then I came
to China. So I've been here I've been
here since um 99 since since graduating
from Yale.
>> Yeah. I was just wondering what your
perspective on how that works is because
to me it's it's so plainly obvious. The
criticism they have for somebody like
mom Donnie for example, I live in New
York City. They are criticizing him for
the way he eats. if he's eating during
an interview or if he's picking up food
with his hand the same way people eat
pizza. But the stuff that Trump gets
away with if I imagining Camela Harris
for example launched a ground troop
invasion or was tweeting the things that
Trump is tweeting every there would be
mass outrage. I'm wondering what the the
key factor is. What is that? Is it a
race thing? What makes people get let
Trump get away with what he's getting
away with? What's the most important
aspect of his rhetoric or the way he
prevents uh presents himself?
>> I think it's just the fact that uh he's
so unpredictable. The fact that like
every single day he's changing his mind
like like you know there was a press
conference where like every sentence was
a contradiction, right? He's like we won
the war. Oh, we lo we're we're not
winning the war but we'll win it. Oh, we
can't win the war. He he he just kept on
going on and on and on. And so when you
become like that, when you are
unpredictable,
people were able to project their
fantasies on to you, right? So for the
MAGA people, Donald Trump is playing a
5D chess game, which is like his real
goal is not to win the war in Iran. His
real goal is is to destroy the deep
state with this war.
Donald Trump if he is to um you know
basically free America of transnational
capital if he's able if he's to liberate
America from the deep state who've been
in power since the 1963 assassination of
JFK
he needs this war to um basically
consolidate power right this war that
the deep state wants this war because
um they want to maintain the American
empire but Donald Trump wants to use
this war to become um a monarch, which
is necessary in order for America to
return to its democratic roots. So for
them, it's this 5D chess.
>> Mhm. And he is flirting with the idea of
running for a third term. JD Vance,
they're trying to separate. Okay. So
he's going to Can you explain how is
that going to work? Is it because it's
wartime?
>> Look,
I think Donald Trump has been very clear
about this. He is going to get a third
term. And the reason why is that if he
ever steps out of office, the Democrats
come to power, the first and only thing
Democrats are going to do is
persecute this guy to death. Okay? I
mean, think about what happened to him
like when he left office in 2020. Yeah.
Right. There there was a FBI raid on
Mara Lago because he had some classified
documents that everyone in Washington
has, right? So everything in in
Washington DC is is classified. And like
they didn't prosecute uh Hillary Clinton
for having a private email server which
is against you know law. They didn't uh
uh prosecute Joe Biden for having
classified documents in his garage in
Delaware. So clearly this was a
political persecution. Right. So you had
that um FBI raid in Mara Lago. you have
lawfare
uh where uh you know six um attorney
generals were trying to um uh prosecute
Donald Trump. You you had these um
lawsuits that were trying to bankrupt
Donald Trump. Um so so like if Donald
Trump were ever to leave office, the
Democrats would just make his life a
living hell. They would not just go
after him, but they would go after his
immediate family, right? Because
remember Don Jr. is a is involved in a
lot of cryptocurrency uh shenanigans. Uh
there's been a lot of insider trading um
in the Trump White House uh this this
past year and it's all very blatant and
there's a lot of evidence to suggest
that this is all in insider trading. Um
so there are a lot of court cases that
that uh they can file against Donald
Trump. But and Donald Trump understands
this. He understands look look I'm doing
all this and I know that if I leave
office I'll be I'll be prosecuted by the
Democrats. So I won't leave office. It's
that simple. Okay. um and and um a lot a
lot of pieces are already in place for
his third term. So, for example, he's
turning ICE into the into his basically
private secret police, his his private
uh police force. Uh and he's he's
expanding their powers. He's uh talked
about deploying National Guard
throughout the country. Um he he might
use this war to suspend the
constitution. Uh there might be a false
flag attack.
um in 2028 he could technically run as a
vice president and have a son Don Jr. as
the president presidential nominee
believe it or not but there's nothing in
the constitution that prevents you from
doing this. It's immoral but it's not
illegal. Also, if the Democrats were to
challenge this, it would go to the
Supreme Court and Donald Trump appointed
three justices to the Supreme Court and
he'll probably appoint two more over the
next two years. So, so he'll have like
like a solid majority. Um, so again, I
don't know the specifics of what they
have have in mind. I think he could run
for a third term as the vice president.
And I think that's the most likely
option,
>> but he could also um as this war gets
worse and worse, he could also suspend
the constitution like Zilinski did in in
Ukraine, right? Um, so I'm pretty
confident he will get his third term,
though.
>> It's not just insider trading. They're
doing these prediction markets and he's
giving pardons to people who are clearly
paying him. The
>> it's so obvious and nobody speaks about
it. You can see the market right before
he gives a speech about when he's going
to attack Iran again because the trade
of Hormuz is closed. So clearly there's
people on the inside that are making
trades, especially uh in the oil market,
but they get away with this organized
crime more than I've ever seen anybody
uh get away with this stuff. And
>> and sorry, but I'm saying he gets away
with it because he's doing the bidding
of the elite, right? The elite wants
this war in Iran and Trump Trump is
doing that. As long as Trump keeps this
war going, then the elite will let allow
him to get get away with anything. But
once um you know, he's out of office
then then he'll he'll be destroyed.
>> Other major predictions? So you're
predicting that there will be a third
term. We saw Mary Menson pretty much
said that she would fund millions more
dollars. What can we expect going
forward? When could the ground troop
invasion inevitably be? Because there
are no signs that we are getting out of
this. Besides them declaring victory,
this seems like it's going to continue
to stretch out.
>> So, I think we're already in a ground
invasion phase because of what happened
this weekend, right? remember there was
this pilot um that had to eject from his
plane, an F-15 that got shot down by by
the Iranians. And uh there was a massive
search and rescue operation for him that
involved hundreds of special forces as
well as possibly a thousands of support
staff. And that was essentially a ground
um invasion that that that was a ground
excursion. And the thing thing about
these things is that like once you set
the president then there'll be more of
these things. So um let let me talk
broadly about what happened this
weekend. Okay. So, the fact that the F
F-15 is shot down shows us that probably
more FT F-15s will be shot down in the
future because the reality is that these
um um jets are not as invisible as
people believe them to be. Also, the
Iranians have shown themselves extremely
creative. Um so rather than use radars I
think they they lock down lock lock uh
on um heat signatures. Okay. And that's
that's something that um the American
military didn't didn't expect. So
Iranians are proving themselves much
more flexible, much more creative and
much more resilient than people assumed
them would be because remember four
weeks ago the Americans according to
Peter Hex had already established a
supremacy meaning all air defense was
knocked out was was knocked um out. The
other problem is that if the Americans
continue with this aerobar campaign,
it's going to cost a lot of wear and
tear because these are very expensive
machines, very sophisticated and very
hard to maintain. They were never
designed to fight a long war. They were
designed to fight a twoe war at at most.
And so as as this thing keeps on going,
you're going to have you're going to
have malfunction which is going to force
these planes to crash into um Iran and
and and and so it's impossible to
sustain an air campaign for too long.
And historically what you do first is
you send in ground forces to clear the
air defenses for your airplanes to come
in to establish a supremacy. And so the
Americans will have no choice but to
eventually use ground forces to pay to
pave the way for the their their air
war. Um so that's the first point I want
to make.
>> Yeah. And it's Yeah. Go ahead.
>> Sorry. Sorry. Go.
>> Yeah. I was just going to let them know
the audience know that the F-15 jet
costs around $90 million. Extremely
expensive. Supposed to be invincible.
Similar to the Gerald Ford. These things
are supposed to be invincible. And
they're declaring that the military is
destroyed, the air force is destroyed,
and their anti-aircraft technolog is
destroyed, the F F-15 being shot down
goes against that narrative completely.
But please continue.
>> Yeah. And the other thing is that during
this rescue operation,
um they lost more planes. I I think a
couple of Blackhawk helicopters were
shot down. two C30s
were stranded and they had to blow blow
blow them up because they they didn't
want the Iranians to to capture their
planes. So the entire operation cost
hundreds of millions of dollars um
billions of dollars actually and I see
people on Twitter who are like this
can't possibly be a rescue operation
because why would the Americans commit
so many resources uh takes takes so many
casualties just to rescue one pilot? It
makes no sense whatsoever. And my my
argument is this. The Americans when
they fight a war, it's not really about
military strategy. It's really more
about optics and narrative, right?
>> So, um, if you are, if you are a special
operator, if you're Delta or Navy,
you're not thinking about how to win
this war. You're thinking about after
this war, can I get a book deal? Can I
get a movie deal? Can I go? I'm serious,
man. This like literally how these guys
think. You've got this culture where
special forces have taken over the
military. They are now the superstars of
the military. And for them, what's
important is that the military revolves
around them and their ego. And this this
is this a problem in the military. And a
lot of people have talked about this
where you've got these primadonas
who think they're the generals and they
refuse to take orders from from from the
from the generals, right? And it's
something that's reinforced in popular
culture where you know you go back to
the um Osama bin Laden capture that was
that was like huge news. Uh and they
made a movie about it and and you know
um these Navy Seals were invited to give
talks and they have book deals and and
all that. So you've got this culture in
the American military and the people uh
the the special operate operators. It's
not about how to win this war. about
like how do I look good in this war? And
that's why America engages in these like
high-risk lowreward operations and this
can be a huge problem as this war
continues because America doesn't have
infinite resources because America can't
afford to like every weekend go rescue a
pilot and spend like you know bill a
billion dollars doing so. Um yeah uh and
and and and and the other thing is look
this is exactly what they did 2003. So
uh there was this private named Jessica
Lynch. Jessica Lynch uh L Y N C H. Okay.
And um her convoy was ambushed by the
Iraqis because it got lost from from
main convoy and she was captured as a
person of war. um she had a lot of a lot
of injuries. So the Iraqis put her in a
hospital, a civilian hospital and then
word got out that she was in a civil
hospital and the Americans had hundreds
hundred hundreds of special forces go
rescue her. It was a very complex
operation that that involved a lot of
different uh branches and this was huge
news in America at that time and it made
America feel good. They made a movie
about it. The problem is that after the
war, Jessica Lynch
gave public talk saying the entire
incident was fabricated by the
Americans. The American military said
that I was a prison of war being raped
by the Iraqis and they had soldiers
guarding me all the time. But the
reality was that I was treated very well
by the doctors and nurses at this
hospital. the sec the the military had
gone away a long time ago and you know
what honestly I could have they wanted
to like bring an ambulance and send me
back to the Americans but the Americans
were shot at this ambulance so they
couldn't do that and you know what if
they had sent a representative from the
American embassy to come and take me
home the Iraqis would have cooperated
instead they had sent hundreds of
special operators with like fake bullets
to stage this commander raid in the
hospital to make it look good on TV um
and to make movies about it.
>> And and and so that's what the American
military does. It's not about winning
wars. It's about looking good. Um so you
you can have a book deal or a movie
afterwards. And there's going to be a
disaster in this war,
>> an optics war. And that was the
justification for it. In the beginning,
they wanted to free the women of Iran of
the oppressive burka. They wanted to
save them from their oppressive regime.
And now it's we are going to send them
back to the stone ages. Even though in
the stone ages, Iran has been an empire
for how long? Thousands of years, but
the American Empire has been around for
less than 250. So, they have completely
abandoned that. I haven't seen anybody
talk about freeing the people of Iran
anymore. And I don't know how they're
going to be able to justify that or how
the Iranian diaspora who are celebrating
this war, how they are justifying the
fact that these uh people in the
administration are bragging and are
encouraging to bomb their power plants,
their water supply and send them back to
literally the stone ages as they're
saying. So, of course, America once we
do these wars that we realize we made
all these mistakes. And not only book
deals, we're probably going to see
movies in 10 years about how much it
hurt the soldiers feelings. There's
going to be another American sniper.
There's going to be soldiers crying.
It's going to be the sad music platoon.
Bradley Cooper will play Pete Hegth.
>> This is just a cycle of our country.
>> Look, this war, this war has been a
dumpster fire, right? Because now the
reason for grind invasion is to control
the shoo allow for maritime uh
navigation. The problem with this is
that before the war the shoo was free to
open to to like maritime navigation. You
you start you start this war and so
that's why the Iranians closed it. Um
now I think like the reason for the
ground invasion is well we need to
destroy the air defenses. Um and like
like the response is well if you didn't
bomb them all the time they you know
they wouldn't have their defenses you
know like like um so it's so war has a
logic momentum of its own. Once you're
in a war it's almost impossible to get
out of it. So this thing will get worse
and worse and one thing that people
don't can't imagine right now is how
devastating this will be for the global
economy right you I mean like um it's
entirely possible that in 6 months time
there will be massive lockdowns in
America and there'll be rationing uh in
America there might be even a national
draft in America you'll have like
national guard deployed everywhere to
control the population in about six
months time
>> and if you watch your lectures they
would give you more credit because it's
the perfect example of the sunken cost
fallacy where once you start losing in
the casino, you don't leave, you keep
investing more money. You keep spending
money on the slot because you need to
recoup the losses that you have now
acrewed. This is by far the best example
of that because they can't retreat.
They've already declared victory.
They've already invested so much money.
It's going to obviously continue. A
draft would be somewhat ridiculous. They
did increase the enlistment age from 35
to 42, meaning now Ben Shapiro, Matt
Walsh, and Daily Wire, they can join. So
many of the people that were too old are
now within the age. So I encourage them
to to go join up and grab an AR-15.
>> When would the draft be? And and would
there be would that be the catalyst for
some sort of
protest at the very least?
>> Um, right. So, I'm not sure if you saw
the news, but Germany has banned
uh military military age men from I
think 17 to like 35 from leaving the
country without permission from the
military.
Did you see that that that news?
>> No. No.
>> Like that's clearly Germany is moving
towards a draft, right? If you are 17 to
35, a ma a male, you're not allowed to
leave the country for more than 3 months
unless you had permission for the
military to do so, which means you can't
leave. Okay? which means that they're
moving towards a draft.
>> I thought NATO
>> Trump's been very critical of NATO and
saying that they weren't going to
support him.
>> Um, right. But I mean, it's all just
theatrics, right? At the end of the day,
NATO does whatever the Americans tell uh
NATO to do because the people running
NATO are American generals. Um so so so
we are going to see a draft in Germany
very very soon both for the war in
Ukraine and also to aid the effort in
the Middle East. Um and I see a very
similar uh dynamic playing out in in
America. So, um um I I think with within
the next 6 months uh the blueprint for
the draft will will will be made
available.
>> And yeah, and I'm not sure uh how young
American men will will respond to the
draft. I mean, you you you'll probably
have better insight than than I do. Um
but I think I think it's going to
dumpster fire. I I I think I think it's
be very hard to get young American men
to agree to go to the Middle East to
die. The other thing is that people
forget this but in America but in the
Vietnam War, one of the major reasons
why Americans lost the Vietnam War is an
issue called fragging. Uh F r a g i n g.
What it means is um American uh soldiers
will kill their commanding officers
uh if they feel their commanding
officers are going to put them at risk.
Uh and this is a huge problem in
Vietnam. Um and it might be a problem um
in the Middle East as well, right? when
we're hearing stories, rumors, I I I I
don't think they're necessarily true,
but like there are rumors that um
sailors are sabotaging their own ships
to avoid um uh being deployed in the
Middle East. Um so I I I think you'll
have if they are sent to war um these
soldiers are going to have very low
morale and you'll see some of them
engage in acts of sabotage.
>> I didn't know that was a major issue in
Vietnam. And again, it
>> it's a huge issue. It was a huge issue.
the draft in Germany. Just the irony of
within 80 years you saw the way Germany
was in the past and now look that
they're going to send their young men
who were once completely literally the
opposition to Israel now dying for them
within 80 years. It shows just how
powerful this empire became. Is there
any empire that has risen to this level
of power this quickly other than Pakuda?
>> Um no not really. I mean, uh, Paxportica
rose very quickly, but they didn't have
as much control as America and, um,
Britain had to share power with the
Russians, the Germans, uh, um, as well.
And, uh, but America is able to do
dominate the world by itself, which
which is incredible. Another comparison
that we can make to what happened 80
years ago in World War II is Ben Gavir
passing this new death penalty. So in
the midst of this war, I think they're
realizing that they can get away with
the Lebanon invasion, but Ben Gavir is
celebrating this new law where
Palestinian prisoners are subject to a
death penalty that is not part of the
law for Jewish prisoners. This is the
first time, if I'm not mistaken, that a
nation has passed a specific death
penalty for one race, but not for
another since Germany in the 30s and
40s. Can Israel keep getting away with
what they're getting away with?
Racial supremacy in Israel is a real
thing. It's not a conspiracy theory.
Okay? If you just look at uh Jewish
theology,
um they believe that they are different
from other people, right? So um um uh
the theology is this and it goes back to
to the cabala. So the idea is that God
create the first man Adam Kenmmont
and um during this creation phase um the
vessel broke okay and so the divine
light broke into 600,000
uh divine roots. And so if you were to
take this theology literally, what what
it's telling you is that there's only
600,000 humans in this world and
everyone else is just an animal soul,
right? And 600,000 are Jewish souls and
quite honestly, everyone else is an
animal that's taking up space. So like
you should try to clear up as as many of
them as possible. So, so there are these
religious extremists in Israel who do
not see anyone outside Israel who is not
Jewish as a human being. And so that
that that's what that's why that phrase
like mowing the lawn, right?
>> You know, like imagine killing people as
like mowing the lawn because, you know,
there are weeds and we have to mow the
lawn.
>> Mhm. Is this the truth about the
whailing wall? I've seen theories that
the whailing wall, the the worship they
do there, it looks like it's, for lack
of a better term, it looks like they're
fornicating with it. The movement is
back and forth. And I heard it's because
of what you're talking about with Cabala
magic that there's a divine feminine and
masculine aspect of God. And that this
wall, though created by the Romans, it
represents the feminine nature of God.
And so these Israelis are literally
having sex with it to try to activate
its feminine divine energy. Is this
correct?
>> Okay. So um
look, I I'm not an expert. I'm not a
rabbi, right? So I can tell you but but
but but let me speculate about how this
works. Okay. So the Cabala says this.
The Cabala says is that God is the will
to bestow. Okay? That's what God is. God
is all love, all generosity, all
compassion and God wants to
uh uh bestow. But if you want to bestow,
you need something to receive, right? So
God what what God does in order to
bestow is create the will to receive,
which is the first man, Adam Kadm. Okay?
Um but the problem with the will to
receive is that if you're all receiving,
you don't understand what bestowing
means, right? So, so let me use a um
allegory. So, let's just say I invite
you to my house and I'm really excited
to meet you and and and share a meal
with you. So, I spent the whole weekend
cooking the most sumptuous meal ever.
It's a 10 course banquet and I'm really
excited to um have you enjoy this meal
and it's the will of the store, right? I
just I just want to be open and generous
with you. But you come to my house and
you look at this sumptuous meal and you
are embarrassed by it. You're confused
by it. You're like, "Oh my god, does he
want to borrow money from me?" Like like
like like what's going on here? And like
you just you're embarrassed by it. So
like you you're like, "Oh my god. Um my
my mom's calling me." So So you run
away. Okay. So So um now I'm like,
"Okay, how how how to get back in so we
can we can share a meal." Okay. So, so
for the cabalis that is the struggle of
life where God is the will to bestow,
humanity is the will to receive but we
refuse to receive God's gift. So what
this means is that we humans need to
engage in a long process of spiritual
alchemy to reduce our ego and to
appreciate the gener generosity of God
for a pro process of redemption and uh
repetence. Okay. But but you can also
frame it as the generative principle
which is God and the productive
principle which is us. Okay. And when
you marry the two then you have
perfection. You you can also see it as
the dynamic of thesis antifosis
symphysis. Okay. But but the goal of
life is a reunion with God. Right? And
that's why you have to build a third
temple because the third temple allows
for God to manifest itself on the world
so that we can be reunited with God. So
it's not really about sex. It's more
about reunion. Um and
because because we're not separate. We
just imagine we're separate and that's
the root of all um of all uh issues.
>> Right. So um so so I I think that that's
what's going on where uh the Jewish
people the the the religious people are
like you know like how do we reunite
with God and this action in the willing
wall. I mean like it's not really about
sex. It's about coming together again,
which which is which is sex basically.
>> Okay. So maybe there's something to that
theory. Now Netanyahu is bragging about
something that you spelled out in your
lectures, which is that greater Israel,
which was a conspiracy theory not too
long ago. You were called anti-semitic
is something that he seems like he's
bragging about publicly in speeches and
that the Lebanon invasion is something
that's going to spread and continue out
throughout the Middle East. Can we
expect this to happen in the near
future? and how much of this blame is
going to be placed on Netanyahu because
I saw Tucker Carlson published the BB
Files documentary. I'm not sure if
you've seen it yet, but a lot of the
information in there was unimportant
from my perspective. I think there were
about 10 minutes that were important in
the BB files towards the end. They were
spelling out how Netanyahu has a signed
document that shows that he was the one
directing the transactions from Qatar to
Hamas. So essentially, he was funding
both sides. This is something that you
spell in your lectures how both sides of
a war are funded by the same people so
that they can direct chaos and outrage
and also profit off of it the most.
Netanyahu essentially wanted Hamas to be
causing chaos so that Gaza would
eventually be destroyed. The hostages
were not a main concern of his because
he wanted to use the Hannibal directive.
He wanted to destroy it completely which
we now see this is happening. And I've
seen a lot of Zionists try to say, "Oh,
it's not all Israelis. It's just
Netanyahu." It's not, "Don't be
anti-Semitic. It's the Israeli
government and it's specific people."
The majority of Israelis hate Netanyahu.
They protest him. They think he's a bad
person. Ben Gavir was called a
terrorist. He's the bad one, not all of
us. What is the validity of that theory?
And when can we see greater Israel?
>> Right. So, first of all, there's been a
long year between Hamas and um
Netanyahu, right? So 1996, I believe it
was 1996, okay? But but but I mean you
can fact check me, he was running for
the first time to be prime minister. He
was way behind the polls and then Hamas
launched a series of bus attacks in in
Israel.
>> Oh, hold on a sec. The audio cut out
>> and and allowed um
>> Yeah, we're better now.
And then um and and then uh remember
right before October 7th, Nanyahu was
fighting for his political life. Uh he
was charged with corruption. He he well
he is corrupt. His entire family is
corrupt. And there were these um special
investigations of Nanyahu and there were
millions of people protesting in the
streets because um Nyahu wanted to
change the uh judiciary. Um and it
seemed as though Na Yahoo was dead
politically. And then October 7th
happened and now he's still in power. So
I I think um Hamas and Netanyahu work
very well together and I think there's a
lot of evidence to suggest that. And
yeah, I mean like we know for a fact
that Qatar is funding Hamas because
Netanyahu has instructed them to do so.
>> Um the um Greater Israel Project uh
Jewish supremacy is something that they
talk about openly in Israel. I mean,
just go to Israel and spend time with
Jews and they'll talk about openly. And
the reason why is that in the Jewish
tradition, it doesn't matter what the
rest of the world thinks. Who cares?
What matters is their relationship with
God. Okay? That that that's the only
thing that that matters. So, as long as
they're able to move towards re reunion
with God, uh move towards redemption of
the Jewish people, that's that's the
only thing that that matters. And for
this redemption to happen, you need you
you need to play out history that that
that requires the fulfillment of the
greater Israel project and the building
of the third temple.
>> Right? So um the idea that this is Ny
Yahoo is absurd. 80% of people support
this war. 80% of Israelis support um
this war against Iran. Um and this
greater Israel project is clearly the
end goal. And this war in Iran is just a
way to achieve this because think think
about what's happening in this war where
eventually the entire world is going to
be drawn in. The GCC uh Dubai, UAE,
Saudi Arabia want this war uh to
continue and want to fight Iran to the
finish and Iran can easily destroy the
GCC, right? But once the GC is GCC is
destroyed, that clears a path for
Israel. Turkey might be drawn into this
war as well. And if Turkey is drawn into
this war, then Iran can destroy it
pretty easily. Um, and then that's
another domino that that thaws.
>> So the end the so this war ends I think
when the United States is forced to
retreat from the Middle East and then
Israel can achieve um the greater is is
uh greater is Israel project.
>> The UAE I've seen some reports I'm not
sure how valid they are that they are
going to join Israel and fight Iran. A
lot of people in the GCC, especially the
Dubai influencers, they thought that
this war was going to be over. They were
saying it was going to be over in 24
hours. They were saying, "Everybody's
panicking. This outrage is unnecessary."
What could we see now over a month into
this war? You said that the GCC would
never have the same reputation again. Is
it really over for these people in the
Gulf States?
>> I think it's completely over. I think
there's no hope. And I I think like
they're desperate. Um, and that's why
they um they they want to enter the war.
You know, really strange, but like last
week I got an email from the Dubai
government inviting me to speak at a
conference in September. I'm like, why
would I go, man? Are you guys going to
be around September? So, so, but yeah.
Um, no, I think I think it's done. Um, I
I think these things are mirages. I
think they were artificial creations. I
mean, the idea I mean, like these are
basically slave societies, right? where
you have the the Emiratis doing nothing.
They're on welfare and then 90% of
people do the work, but they're all
expatriots and it and it's it's it's a
um cast system where expatriots are
given like you know these very lavish
salaries and then um people from the
third world mainly Pakistan, India,
Africa are treated as slaves in in that
society.
>> Yeah, I'm seeing the footage now also
Bengalis are out there. They're finally
able to go on the beach and so you can
see them all these workers flooding
through. Actually, a mirage is the
perfect analogy for it. A mirage. The
idea that this uh fantasy land created
in the middle of the desert. That's
essentially what you could describe it
as. I don't want to get banned by the
UAE for insinuating that. So,
>> I uh I'm not but they are very strict
about that. What about uh I I don't want
to hold you up too much of your time,
but with the professor conversation
coming up from Medi Hassan, I think a
lot of people are making the comparison
between you and Jordan Peterson. I'm not
sure if he's still on Daily Wire. Have
you compared yourself or your careers to
him? And what lessons can we learn?
Because his reputation is not the same
as it once was. He was very popular
during the woke push from Larry Fank as
he's now admitted. But nowadays he has a
mental health problem which I mean you
you did admit that it was getting
difficult for you in March. How could we
learn from Jordan Peterson's career?
I think that Jordan Peterson is a
brilliant teacher, right? And if you go
back and watch his uft uh lectures, he
had a way of engaging his students. He
had a way of showing himself
um that um made him very charismatic. Um
that made him an exemplar, a role model
for young people. And um if he just
focused on that, I think he could have
been a positive force in the world. But
his mistake was this. His mistake was
when he became popular, he monetized
himself. So, I think there's this clip
of him talking about how much money he
makes and he's like, "Why make, you
know, $60,000 I I I'm just making this
up, okay? But I'm saying, I make $60,000
a week doing lectures. I make $20,000 a
week doing book sales. I make $30,000 a
week on Patreon." And like like
I know it's a lot of money and it's very
tempting but when you get seduced by
that money um you have to sell your
soul. I think I I I I I think yeah you
you want to uh monetize to a certain
extent and I do monetize. I mean like I
I don't monetize my YouTube but I
monetize my substack and that's a lot of
money. Um it's nowhere near how much
Jordan Peterson makes. I think the Daily
Wire gave him $60 million for his IP,
right? So, that's a lot of money. But,
um, you have to remember
that this is how they control you. This
is how they get you with money, right?
So, remember after October 7th, Na Yahoo
um said, "Give them give them hell,
Israel." Right? So, he came out vocally
in support of Israel. Um, and you
shouldn't do that. I mean, you you as a
teacher, you want to maintain some um
impartiality. You want to maintain some
distance. You want to maintain
perspective. And but he was taking so
much money from these people that he
felt that okay, they're my friends.
They're in trouble. I need to speak out.
And then he got a lot of backlash for
for for that. But that's how that's how
they get you. They get you through
money. Okay. So, I don't monetize my
YouTube. And everyone's like, "You're
insane. You could be generating a lot of
money through YouTube and you do a great
job on YouTube. So, why why not just
take the cash and enjoy your life?" And
the answer is because I don't want them
to control me, right? So, it's a
signaling mechanism where like I'm
telling them I don't I don't want to
monet monetize my YouTube. So, don't
talk come talk to me. I'm going to shut
the door on you. The devil can only come
in if you let if you let him in. Okay?
You have to invite the devil in. And I'm
not gonna invite you guys in, so don't
bother.
>> Right? I don't care what you do to me,
but I'm not going to take your money.
I'm not going to make a deal with you.
You're not gonna and and like like
because what I care about is my my soul.
What cares about is being a teacher. And
I I think that's a mistake that Jordan
Peterson made. And like quite honestly,
once you make this mistake, you're
stuck, man.
>> You are now bought. And if you want to
like,
you know, change the terms of the
contract, if you want to be like, you
know, like, I'm sorry, this was not a
good deal. I'll give back all your
money. Well, certain things can happen
to you.
>> Mhm.
>> You know,
>> that was my favorite statement from the
first interview we did was that the real
wealth is knowledge. Real wealth is not
something, you know, not Rothschild [ __ ]
books, as I like to say. It doesn't come
from fame. It doesn't come from any of
these worldly things. It comes from the
pursuit of something greater,
enlightenment, as you say. It's
something that I think that is more
important than ever to pursue right now,
especially if the US dollar collapses,
which right now the chairman of the
Federal Reserve is saying that look at
the writing on the wall. This does not
look good. The United States just hit
$39 trillion in debt. And this system is
only based off of our belief in it. It's
only because we believe in this currency
that it holds any weight. People die
trying to accomplish and trying to
achieve this wealth, this money that
literally means nothing besides the
stock that we place into it with our our
own minds. And so being in in control of
your own mind is the most valuable thing
we can do in terms of resistance and
revolution. As long as you maintain true
independence and you don't rely upon the
state, especially when AI is replacing
so much of that authority figure, they
want to control what's in here. That
this is what makes you who you are.
That's your soul. So more than ever,
that is important. Do you think your
audience is predominantly young people?
Because you always reiterate how
important it is. Obviously your classes,
you know, you teach a high school, but
do you think that your influence is with
the future?
Um, so I've looked at some
analytics and um well, first of all, my
audience is heavily skewed towards male.
So about 90% male, 10% female. Um u the
other thing is that the the demographic
tends to be middle-aged. So maybe from
like 35 to 45. Um and the and um um um
most are in the Anglosphere, right?
the United States um and um Europe,
Canada.
Um and I think a lot of it is these are
people who received an education and
they were not happy with their education
and they've had some life experience and
they're confused by how the world works.
And so when they watch my videos, it's
almost like a confirmation or validation
of their doubt in the world. But I but I
think you need a certain knowledge set.
I think you you need um a certain
experience in order to appreciate my
teachings. So I'll I'll give an example
where you know like it's possible like
for one video I have two million views.
Okay? So there are two people 2 million
people watching my videos. In my class,
my high school class there are two
students guys. Okay, like there are no
su. So yeah, there are two students in
my class because they're too young.
They're like 18. They don't know
anything, you know, they and and and
they're happy golucky. So um most
students find my class very depressing.
Um but I feel as though that that's what
education is. Education is about self
annalation in order to form your a
proper um more free understanding of how
the world works. You know, basically
destroy your brainwashing.
>> Mhm. So, what should the future
generations what should we invest in?
Say the American empire collapses. Do
you recommend people like me, should we
stay in America? Last time you said that
Bitcoin and cryptocurrency was
predominantly infiltrated by secret
societies. I'm not trying to
mischaracterize what you said, but
essentially that crypto is not as
reliable as many people believe. Where
do you think besides wealth and
knowledge, where do you see the future
for us?
>> Look, I think for young people um in the
20s, the best thing you can invest in
right now are human relationships. So,
cook dinner together, right? Be generous
to to each other. Go out and hike
together. Um it does it it sounds kind
of weird now but I guarantee you um if
you were to do this and just focus on
building relationships like building
friendships
and focusing on emotional bonds with
each other. This is going to be such the
mo this this will be the best investment
you will make in the future world
because a new world is world is coming
and people are going to have to stick
together in order to survive this this
world. It's entirely possible that, you
know, we'll have to move out of the
cities and go back to farming. It's
entirely possible this happens. In which
case, it's it's probably important to
have a community of people that you
trust, that you love working together,
to grow food together, to support each
other, to have families together.
>> Yeah. Establishing real relationships.
It's something that since this war
started, I can kind of relate to your
apprehension to upload and the pursuit
of travel and wanting to spend personal
time and seeing how it could affect
people around you because I also I' I've
noticed I'm not sure if you have, but
you've done a great job. You don't
really you don't attack anybody. People
come at you and you don't really seem to
respond, but since the war started, I've
also been sleepless. Even like in this
interview, I have I hardly been sleeping
beforehand. and I I don't feel as sharp
as I uh wanted to be or was in previous
interviews with you. I've been editing
too much and just looking at the news
too much, interacting on Twitter too
much. What have you realized is the the
way to stay away from that chaos and and
how can what advice would you give to
really be strong amidst all the
craziness we see online?
>> Right. So, I think the another mistake
that Jordan Jordan Peterson made was too
much online engagement where he was
actually responding to his critics on
social media. And what you need to
recognize is that most people are
trolls. They're just they're just trying
to provoke a response from you and like
they're just trying to make you angry.
And so, my number one rule is
do not respond online. If you want to
have a conversation with me, let's do it
um with in a conversation, right? A long
form conversation conversation where
you're allowed to present your
perspective and where I'm allowed to
present my my perspective. But like I
don't be a keyboard warrior where I'm
where, you know, I'm debating um my
critics online because they'll be much
more effective at trolling me than I am
them. So my number one rule is do not
respond
um to social media. Like I receive
social media and I look at comments now
and then but I don't read YouTube
comments. My wife does. My wife reads
YouTube comments. I do not read YouTube
comments. Okay? So I apologize if I
don't respond. Okay? And I try not not
not to read comments. I I just try to
focus on being me. I try to focus on
trying to form a coherent understanding
and framework for the world. I don't
want to be disrupted by this. Okay? So I
don't engage online but I also don't
engage offline as well. Meaning I don't
go and give lectures. I don't go and
meet fans, you know, and and and like,
you know, I'm sorry um if if I seem
antisocial, but again, it's it's it's
it's to protect my personal health, my
mental health. It's to protect my
family.
>> Uh and it's to ensure that I can be the
best when I go teach in the classroom.
>> That's a mindset that I need to
definitely adapt. It's different
because, you know, we grew up with
social media. So that troll nature is
pretty much ingrained in so many of our
it's ingrained in our DNA to be engaging
and I I have to figure out yeah I've
always noticed that it's better when
you're just creating when you're
producing and you're actively trying to
make it better. That's when you're at
your happiest and that's when actually
you are the best creator. As soon as you
get involved in the cesspool that's when
your your energy is pulled away and
you're not making anything. you're just
engaging and giving people attention and
all they really want is is attention.
It's uh it's extremely important and you
don't really seem like you have felt the
temptations to get involved in that
which is uh definitely part of your
success.
So I mean the thing to know about me is
that I've been famous before. uh people
people forget but like I am China's like
most famous educator and so I get
interviewed by uh New York Times, Wall
Street Journal, BBC all the time and in
in my early 30s I blew up online because
of certain interviews I did about
Chinese educ education system. I'm very
critical of it and I was googing myself
every day. Um, and at a certain point
I'm like, why am I googling myself every
single day? This is silly. And I I
understand like the sort of the rush,
the it's like a drug, right? Like, oh my
god, all this attention and you're
googling myself to see like how many
news reports uh you use your name. And
um so I've been there. I've done that.
You know, it's it's it's I I understand
like what the feeling is. I understand
how you know like if you just start
focusing on your own fame um it makes
you anxious it makes you it fame is
really a drug right where you know if
today you got like 10,000 views but the
next day you get a th000 views then you
you just fall into a deep depression and
and so I I've been there and I've done
that and and and so I know how to
protect myself now.
>> Yeah. It's when your self-worth is
derived through numbers on a screen.
That's another form of currency. You're
controlled in that way. The same reason
that people like Jordan Peterson were
able to be controlled. So yeah, I I wish
you the best of success. Please don't
quit. We want to keep watching the
lectures. And those students name it's
Amber. What's the other student's name?
I can't remember.
>> Well, um there's Vincent and there's
Allan. They're the most consistent.
Yeah, they're the most consistent. And
then Amber comes down then. So there's
three. Yeah.
>> So the conspiracy theory that you're
speaking to an empty classroom that's
been debunked. You have videos where you
can meet the students in the class and
they are
>> they ask questions.
>> Yeah, they do.
>> And they do ask questions at at the end
of the class. Yeah.
>> Sometimes you get annoyed with Vincent's
questions. Sometimes Amber could read a
little bit faster. Okay. If you could
please ask her to to read a little more
emotion,
you know, when she's reading stuff about
Greek Empire and stuff. It's just a
little too monotone for for my taste and
I I have to skip over and read it
myself. But I I look forward to it. I I
subscribe to your Substack. I highly
recommend people subscribe to it.
There's been great updates. I think you
post there how often? Maybe twice, three
times a week.
>> Uh I I post once a week. So my subsec is
different in that I try to pose long
form analysis of the war because you
know like like people on Twitter and
people get news and what I'm trying to
do is I'm trying to provide a deeper
analysis of how to connect the current
events together.
>> Mhm. I want to correct a mistake
earlier. It is because I'm tired. I I
said uh Angel Griel instead of angel el.
But it was jin. It was a jin, not an
angel. I've not been sleeping properly
at all for
>> for like the past month.
>> And uh last thing I just want to ask
you, what sort of I don't know, you
probably hardly see my content and I I
guess I I did ask it, but do you have
any how do you think from your view from
Professor Jang's view that I could
improve in this space?
>> Yeah. You know, I think like what would
be really interesting is if like rather
doing like online interviews, you
actually invited people and do like
inerson uh conversations.
>> You're all the way in China. You're far
you're all the way to different time
zone.
>> Well, we can meet somewhere, you know. I
mean, um if you're ever traveling, you
know, I I I could meet you somewhere.
But but but but I'm saying like if
you're able to talk to person people in
person that I think is um much more
effective. Um so I I highly recommend
like more in-person interviews. Another
thing that I think um um is maybe try to
bring different people together, right?
So I would love to have a convers
conversation with David Ike and you
could moderate it. um that that I I I
think would be really interesting for
uh people if that goes well. I'm also
talking I'm also interested in talking
to Dugan. Uh I'm not sure if you know
who he is, but he's he's
Russian
>> and um and I'm very like like we we're
we're online friends, so I can arrange
that very very easily. I I don't know
David Ike uh and he he hates me for
whatever reason. Uh so you you have to
get in touch with him yourself, but I
can I can get in touch with David uh
with actually Dugan and um and I I I
think what what might be interesting is
if there's more like different people
together having having a conversation.
>> I don't know if you were up to that. A
lot of people have been suggesting that,
but I wasn't sure. I I never
>> I'm completely I'm completely up to like
a long form good faith discussion.
>> There's Do you know George Galloway?
I do. Yes, he's interviewed me. Yes.
>> Okay, perfect. And also, do you know
Professor Mirandi?
>> I've not I I actually don't know. I I
have deep respect for him and what he
does. I mean, it's incredible the work
he's been doing. I mean, like, he's he
doesn't sleep. Um he's he's been just
been the most passionate and articulate
advocate uh for Iran.
>> So, after the David Ike interview, I'm
going to do my best to set that up. Open
invitation. I think the next one should
definitely be with Professor Mandi. I
think that would be a a great
conversation to facilitate. I'm not sure
when you're next available. I'll email
you about that. And then George
Galloway, I thought that he was very
interesting to speak to.
>> I think he had a good perspective on uh
social spaceism and a lot of people were
saying, "Oh, look, you're just buying
into that ideology." No, it's right now
there's a debt crisis, there's a housing
crisis, and the elite class control it.
It's not that I'm a a far leftist like
people are trying to categorize me at. I
never say left and right. It's all about
right and wrong. And somebody needs to
address that problem instead of, you
know, we're spending $200 billion
dollars. Well, they want$200 billion
more dollars from the Pentagon. Trump is
saying that he can't afford daycare and
Medicare for all because of all these
senseless wars.
>> Yeah. He's honest like like you know
that's that's what what makes Trump so
um so annoying to liberals because he's
just honest about everything, right?
Liberals prefer that you just lie and be
hypocritical whereas Trump's like, "Nah,
screw that. I I'll be honest. I'm
telling you right now, I can't we can't
afford daycare because we're starting we
have this warning around and like that's
his truth. Sorry, man.
>> That's I think they tried to wipe that
from the internet, but he can just say
it right in front of our faces and and
we continue to eat it up. But these
conversations, community and knowledge,
all this is important to resist what's
coming. So, I I look forward to these
future conversations. Professor Jen, I
will continue to call you this as a sign
of respect in Chinese culture.
>> It's always a pleasure to have you on. I
appreciate your time. Uh, God bless you
and I will look forward and schedule
future conversations.
>> Great. Thanks. Thanks so much, Nigel.
Bye-bye.
>> Bye.
Great interview.
Great interview. My apologies for the
mistake on Angel Gabriel. I am exhausted
right now. I'm very, very tired. I
thought that was a great interview. W's
up in the chat. Always a pleasure to
have Professor Jang on. I have not been
I could really feel it. I don't know if
you guys can tell it, but I've been
editing non-stop and I was sick
beforehand. I've not been resting and
it's been a lot. And I' I've been uh
yeah, it's it's been a lot especially
since the war saw it, but I'll be back
on the schedule uh tomorrow. I'll be
back on that, you know, doing the 8 to
10 hours every single day. Would you
guys best one yet? Let's go.
Let's go. And shout out to everybody
watching this on YouTube as well. Thank
you so much. I saw that you guys loved
the first two interviews and so looks
like we're going to continue the this
back and forth. And best of luck to
Professor Jang with Patrick David
tomorrow.